boxing to me is
there's something mythical about it
there's something incredible about
uh someone who is a pugilist and even if
they're knocked down they get up and
they continue to fight
and it it there's something about boxing
that
has a resurrection to it
in that someone can be a champ and they
can be beaten but then they can come
back
so um
i love boxing rustom came to me and said
we got to work together and you know he
he gave me this action piece and i said
great
but when he gave i said what do you have
something that's close to your heart
and he says yeah but they'll never want
to make it i said well let me see that i
like a challenge and he showed me that
we showed it to jeanette
zao who financed and helped us produce
and showed it to andrew and we were on
our way i mean and it's it was something
that
it was his vision and rustum
you know there was a real vision in that
screenplay
and andrew we were talking a little
earlier about the films that attracted
you when you were growing up that that
it wasn't the what you call the popcorn
films it was the bicycle thief and films
like that and yeah i've i've always
been
attracted and drawn to movies that have
something to say that have that appeal
to the heart and then have something to
say about human nature and where we are
in society and how we can grow as human
beings and how we can make the world a
better place
and
early in
my youth i was very influenced by
european cinema by fellini and bergman
and antonioni and dasika and
by the ability that these filmmakers had
to affect emotion and to be able to draw
you into characters
and throughout i've always looked to try
to make movies that i felt really made a
difference and you know i've been
involved in a lot of movies that
ultimately i think
you could live without on the universe
but
every now and then i get involved in a
movie that is is got
the kind of heart and soul that that
really makes
me tick and makes me want to wake up in
the morning and when i got this script
and daryl said
show me the script and said we're going
to make this movie and we want you to
come on as a producer and i went really
and literally i i read it on i was on my
way to europe and read it on the plane
and i was like
when how how soon can i get to a phone
and call
and tell them that i mean and i want to
do this this is amazing
and i think that's the way a lot of
people have responded to this you know
this is a people story and it's so hard
in our business right now to make
people's stories
um especially the way the studios are
gravitating towards ted paul movies and
action movies
i think although the this uh this film
the power of tell people you know
hold on the dreams and never give up
that's touched my heart and i think the
audience will get this key point in
front but the contents
yes every project is different
every score is very different every crew
is very different
when i get a movie i always sit and
watch the movie i think like um
do i have a chance
is it coming
today is it coming for this movie and it
always comes
so in one way i i
responded well for the
uh for the idea for the idea of this
movie with rustam and
this
with this movie because it was
in a way what i what i do that's why i
feel it's it's coming it's coming
without
without control
and so just like
out of a dream no in dream i i sit in
front of
piano or computer and i i write and
write in right and this is not right and
this is not right and this is not right
and i always believe
one day it comes and it's gonna be right
i don't know this movie was such a
magical experience for me i just really
loved it i loved everything about it i
loved the process in fact when i
finished it it was very odd because i
just threw down so hard and then i was
like oh all right now it's done okay
i'm sure you felt are you ambled on i
did amble on to school
and
tom tom arnold your character is such an
optimist
there's always something exciting about
the prospect of something good happening
and
it's very touching and very poignant
considering the circumstances this man
lives in how did you go about
constructing that character for yourself
well first of all uh i got uh i'd had a
hernia surgery i was in the hospital and
my my manager called and said uh
i thought he mentioned rustom and he and
he said they were doing a movie with i
thought he said mr bean
and uh i was like i am in
because i
passed out a movie in the 90s with mr
bean
and then i the morphine wore off and he
said it was sean bean and uh i love sean
bean
and uh he's different you know and
i have a thing about you know i worked
with steve coogan and and uh
and hugh grant
you know there's guys from over there
they're a little different and uh
i didn't know if he was a
method guy or i just thought well this
will be interesting we're supposed to be
friends i don't know how that's going to
work and
and uh so i said i should probably love
this guy
like for the minute i meet him there i
should think he's the coolest guy i've
ever met
and that's kind of you know i'm pretty
not a guy that admits that he's lonely
but he's obviously lonely he's looking
for a friend and
someone he can be cool with
and uh that's what happens and then you
know hook up with kate
real life and
uh
on the
movie you had a wonderful room you
reminded me so much of the i grew up in
ottumwa iowa and there's a small town
there's so many people
like that that are just working and
getting by and they do have that faith
and
you i've seen liberals mock that a lot
it's ridiculous it's it's a market it's
it's you know it's their thing you know
i have people in my own family
and uh
sometimes you are jealous of that you're
like how do i how do i get there but
you seem so different than kate than
yourself you know you're a viewer that
the [ __ ] was on top of you like oh it
was like all the time yeah
you know you needed a little bit of me
in your life that's what you needed
but i did feel like our scene where we
started dancing oh there's a bear burst
it's like awesome yeah
here's two principles from the cast so
for andrew and daryl and then you have
sean bean as well um
how significant was that casting to
putting the whole thing together to the
synergy of getting it produced financed
sold out here i have to say that
jeannette was incredibly patient and
cooperative with us uh she said you know
you have to get a less casting for this
movie and um
we were
you know we knew that the only thing we
had to offer was the script because
there was not money that we could really
offer so the only thing we had was was
the script and we got a tremendous
amount of support at the end from tracy
brennan at caa who kind of was the
catalyst who got things started and
brought in
pretty much in a very short period of
time very quickly kate and sean bean and
eva laguardia almost all at once and
then we all went like okay wow and then
we just almost immediately like within
days after that
brought in tom so the casting
happened very very quickly
and everybody responded to the script
and we were in the fortunate position of
having material that people responded to
so that we could attract the right
actors for it
what appears in this film and it doesn't
in a lot of films is a very obvious
sense of faith you talked to kate about
that
as well and so for to arrest him when
you were working on this film
how do you strike that balance you don't
want to make a religious move i mean
it's not cecil b demille you know goes
to the inland empire but
it it does have a very profound strain
of faith we see it in kate we see it in
nolan gross the little boy
how do you balance that and make it
credible and important to the characters
but not let it take over the film
that's an incredible question about the
uh element of faith and how do you uh
sort of modulate the faith
and the hope and
the way i viewed this in terms of the
the narrative and what one of the
underlying themes of the narrative is
in in terms of faith is that
the
central character our protagonist has a
transformation
and transformation is something that's
rare in most humans
and
and
oftentimes transformation it comes from
when someone is in the darkest place
that they're they hit a bottom and they
reach a level
where
they're they have the gift of
desperation
and
so what i was going for is
you know you know kate says you know
there's the element of you know she's
going you know
her son says i'm going to church and he
says there's nothing there for me and
there's that going on but it's really
church is ultimately sort of an
allegory
for the light
where this is a man who's in the dark so
it's really ultimately a story of a man
that comes from the dark into the light
and actually he does have sort of a
mystical experience which ultimately is
what turns him